I didn't were you were there that day
yes I was there okay so I was at the
celebrity theater with a [__] that was
not my girl at the
time and I was I was I hosted this y
concert it's on
YouTube it's at the Celebrity Theater
it's the most struggle whack ass local
crooked ass promoters of all time cuz
they had 150 local artists opening up so
y's on so late bro like and it wasn't
even y'all's fault it was cuz there was
so many so when by the time YG gets on
the crowd is so annoyed pissed off like
I've never I've never saw a opener list
for a show it was insane after that whyg
St like no I literally said guys you
guys got me [__] up if you think I'm
gonna walk out there and introduce all
these people like tell me I'll go on
stage three times I already got paid
nonetheless someone starts banging on in
the crowd throwing up some [__] that I
I'm not privy to what it meant but Y and
mustard did not take too kindly to it
rest in peace slim 400 slim hun did not
take too kindly to it rest in peace and
then [__] just starts getting thrown and
at the time there's these metal laptop
stands called Uber stands that were very
heavy and DJ Mustard took the Uber stand
and I remember just seeing it like oh it
chucked it at somebody in the cow it was
[__] insane it's on YouTube you could
go watch it it was a world a early world
star hit that's when I used to have hair
and at that time it kind of [__] up YG
in Phoenix bro just in Phoenix bro that
[__] [__] like this be the thing
people don't realize like also I don't
think a lot of people know Las Vegas
Metro wasn't [__] with Y for a long
time I still don't know if they are by
the way them incidents like that last
for so long like cuz cuz y should have
had a a residency by now in Vegas but
there's a reason why he hasn't right
he's he's not not necessarily the Las
Vegas Metro don't look too fondly upon
at a certain point in time they have a l
shout out shout out to Las Vegas well
they have a list in Vegas shout out to
Dre shout out to no but there's a list
in Vegas the cops have a list so mazy's
on that list but why just because of the
game but you know it's so [__] up cuz
like even with the last [__] we got
banned from Vegas for like there's no
like I don't understand what what this
thing with fans like why a fan can
harass you
and get away with it like and that's the
part like of this music industry like
it's like you can follow me for 20
minutes straight you can call me all
types of [__] all types of hoes you
can aggravate me [__] you can stand
that do whatever you want to you can get
in my face spit at me whatever soon as I
quote unquote as the talent or as the
ACT try to defend myself then it's a
lawsuit of course unfortunate like I
don't I just don't understand like
that's what you got gloves for for if
gloves hit them it's still a lawsuit I
mean yeah I guess you're right look look
like gloves could just shake the [__]
out of somebody bro if gloves does this
somebody's going to the hospital so uh
shout out to YG obviously shout out
Westbrook shout out James Harden how how
hard was it CU there was a
stigma that like y was just trouble and
I know it affected his pockets for a
while but I feel like you guys have
gotten on the other side of that for the
last five or six years very very
successfully but there was that era like
when you guys were on tour with MC with
MC Miller you know what I'm saying like
who was was someone else was on that
tour was it Travis Porter Travis Porter
so random that was bro you know what's
so crazy bro that was one of my favorite
that was Travis Porter is a group three
guys three guys yeah three guys Oh I
thought man cuz what's that song they
used to have then hey ladies they had a
lot of hits make rain the Migos before
the Migos I a't going to lie I thought
that was like one person I never making
like La [__] low key they had BPM [__]
going up out here yeah but I was I'm
wondering like what did y'all like was
there a certain point in time where like
you guys had to like really be like hey
we got to chill with the overreacting or
cuz the brand is leg like I feel like
y's done such a good job of transforming
his brand of being like high fashioned
like he moves like a superstar now and
not like a a [__] gang member from La
I just feel like you know you get to a
point and you start seeing things for
what it is like and you have to move a
little different for the respect because
it's like you can get people from other
states they can talk the same [__] they
can wear Rags they can do all this [__]
but because they're not from La it's
like it's it's part of the art but
because we from La it's like oh they're
really that it's like I don't know that
[__] that [__] just be kind of crazy to
me cuz I'll be listen to records and be
like bro that [__] said way crazier
[__] than we said on swoop and it's like
how but it's just I feel like it's a
world stick because it's like when you
think about gangster you think about the
West Coast for sure like so it's like
you just automatically attach his name
to whatever has came from the west coast
and then it's like well he was he like I
mean listen y'all was moving around
[__] but but this the thing though
but were we you got to ask yourself
right were we looking for trouble how
many no no but how many deep at at we
look for trouble was it 40 deep but were
we looking for trouble no but y'all
but think about this though how how many
people young jezy move around with I
have no [__] idea at this point when
y signed a young jezy and we moved to
Atlanta we thought that we moved around
deep he was moving around with 100
people everywhere he went yeah so it's
like but because we from La it's a
different stigma no for sure for sure
but like at the same time I just think
like bro even if you look back and look
at all them incidents like we know who
we are and where we come from we never
looked for trouble but if you came to us
with it like I think too like what we
supposed to do turn he's in a position
now where he's kind of like hey bro like
this dude is like I said the biggest La
rapper we've had in the last 10 more
cult relevant like 15 for sure you know
what I'm saying so I think it's like
when you think of YG I think like he's
he gets held to an unfair standard here
sometimes amongst like some of the young
like generation I'm feel like it's easy
to hate on y or a point be like why Ain
you like I'm like bro YG has been
holding this [__] down
for years outside though on the like for
real holding it down like it's not like
he switched up and started doing like
weird pop [__] like no this is like this
guy's been the same D [__] for sure and
uh you can go buy his clothes as Zoomies
you know who else can say that you know
but you know they don't talk about that
he had a collection in Barney they don't
talk about that it's like what type of
La dude you know has real La clothes
being sold in Barney but people don't
they don't put that up like oh can't
believe YG had a show and Barney like oh
yeah so Rapp y was also involved in such
and such yeah but that was I mean were
you who was with when he when he got
shot were you there nah me and mustard
um wasn't there but we had found out and
we went straight to the hospital man
it's been a scary time bro in La that
was a crazy that was a crazy but is I I
still say that to say is like I don't
just put that on La no but I mean if we
think about the incidents that have
happened with hop artists in the last
six seven years A lot of them have
happened here not all of
them yeah but it's like in what
situation I mean there's plenty of
situations so many people there's so
many rappers I know that have been
robbed that the blogs don't know about
when a th% but you know the crazy [__] I
know so many rappers who go to Atlanta
get Happ in Atlanta too they ain't no
blogs right it happens in Atlanta New
York and geted downstairs of the studio
it happens everywhere it's like bro I
don't think it's a la I think I think
what it is is here everyone's hanging
out in the same on the same [__]
Street for the most part so if like
you're a Jack boy you know where to hang
out at you know what I'm saying like
Atlanta's so like no it's the same [__]
because like this look bro how how many
people get killed at the Linux Mall how
many people get robbed at the Lin you
Len Mall
active us L Mall Lin Mall isn't Linux
Mall isn't in the hood that's a suburbs
right that's like [__] getting robbed
at the Beverly Center or getting robbed
on melr it's the same [__] you feel me
just like because it's Hollywood but a
it's it's like this whole stigma bro
that gets [__] up it's like bro when
you come to La we got downtown we got La
we got Hollywood the
valley I'm not even talking about the
valley shout out to the valley though
but we got La we got downtown and we got
Hollywood when you go to these other
places you got the city and you got
downtown right that's it subur
but yeah no for sure you feel me so it's
like where is it happening at where the
stars but it's like bro [__] is
getting robbed in New York and trica
[__] getting robbed outside the
Supreme cour we just don't hear about it
as much exactly yeah for sure um all
right so your album's on the way yeah
what's it you have a
name you got a name for the album go and
tell them yeah my side of town all right
on me
coming from from soon the east side yeah
coming soon yeah very very soon probably
like in a week or two oh [__] okay uh
and then you you your Studios called
creative creative sounds sounds just had
our 2-year anniversary it was [__]
crazy I had G herbo ogz baby Stone
gorillas RCI and gutter and perform in
my parking lot and you uh can tell me a
y album's on the way soon a y album sexy
red single on the way soon very very
soon sexy red single might come before
this this this interview drop okay well
I mean the video shot that means it's
it's it's go time same for gut every
every video shot you know and he's
editing them himself smart guy hey man
all you artists out there take a page
out of his book stop [__] depending
on other people edit your own [__] yeah
I got my own camera too go on YouTube
and learn some [__] for sure that's all
you got to do well look we're going to
drop a freestyle with this guy uh so
make sure you uh go check that video out
and um shout out to you guys' ig's gut
Bren on all platforms how you you don't
spell g u d d b r v c k i n yeah the v's
where yo follow me everywhere at Pusher
Rod um follow the studio at creative
sounds recording I'm here real West Side
[__] boom I'm an East Side [__] from
the West Coast fire